it's the flattening of the curve you the
increases slowdown flattens out for a
period of time nobody knows how long
because nobody's been here before
but if you look at the number of total
admissions 18,000 80,000 80,000 18,000
that's definitely a flattening that is
good news still going up a little bit by
the way go back a second still going up
a little bit but a basic flattening as
opposed to increasing gaps the total
number of hospitalizations net down a
little bit up a little bit down but
overall just follow the line don't get
caught up in the day-to-day as we say
the three-day rolling average was which
is more accurate than any one day is
down again the net change and ICU
admissions is is down again I discount
this ICU admissions because the old
demarcation of an ICU bed in the
hospital and a regular bed in the
hospital is gone almost every bed is
basically an ICU bed net change in ICU
admissions is also down intubations is
real intubations is the worst signal
people who are intubated wound up on a
ventilator most often do not come off
the ventilator
somewhere 70% 80% depending on who you
talk to so this is a scary number when
that's down it's good and that is down
the three-day rolling averages down so
that's good news we were worried about
the spread from New York City to suburbs
upstate and we have been very aggressive
when we get a little cluster a spot
that's acting up we jump on it
this is like watching a fire going
through dry grass with a strong wind and
it's blowing the fire and a couple of
embers wind up on one side of the field
and embers start to catch fire and
that's a cluster and you have to run
over to those embers and stamp
right away before they grow but you see
the stabilization there and that has
been good too
this is a new take on it
we talked about net hospitalizations
this is the number of new kovat
hospitalizations to date this is how
many new Cova diagnoses or people
walking into the hospital had covered so
you see still about 2,000 people per day
or walking in or being diagnosed with
Kovich so you're still increasing the
hospital population initially by 2000
people who are testing positive for
colvett but on the other side of the
healthcare system peeing people are
being discharged on the other end so the
net is what we talk about because we've
always been worried about lack of
capacity in the hospital system where
you where you pour the water into the
glass and the glass overfill where the
hospital system just can't handle the
number of people coming in and that's
why we've been studying the net but this
says you know take a deep breath you
still have 2,000 people per day who are
coming into the hospital system and the
terrible news is as terrible as it gets
in the worst news I've had to deliver to
the people of this state as governor of
New York and the worst news I've had to
live with on a personal level number of
deaths is is 671 not as bad as it has
been in the past but basically flat and
basically flat at a horrific level of
pain and grief and sorrow this is 671
people who passed away on Easter Sunday
for me I'm Catholic Easter Sundays
the High Holy Day in many ways and one
of the High Holidays and to have this
happen over this weekend is really
really especially tragic and they are
all in our thoughts and prayers the that
raises the death total to ten thousand
fifty six again for perspective ten
thousand twenty seven hundred lives were
lost in 9/11 and 9/11 changed every New
Yorker who was in a position to
appreciate on that day what happened and
the number of live losts lives lost was
horrific after 9/11 and the grief was
horrific
and we are at 10,000 deaths New York
10,000 deaths New Jersey 2,000 deaths
Massachusetts 756 and then you have the
state of Michigan why New York why are
we seeing this level of infection
well why cities across the country it's
very simple it's about density it's
about the number of people in a small
geographic location allowing that virus
to spread and that virus is very good at
what it does it is a killer it is very
good at spreading it is very contagious
and the dense environments are its
feeding grounds we learned that lesson
very early on remember we had one of the
first hotspots in the nation one of the
most intense clusters was New Rochelle
New York New Rochelle is in Westchester
County it's not in New York City why New
Rochelle and that's what I was so
concerned about early on we didn't know
what what we were looking at why New
Rochelle because in New Rochelle one
person or two people who were infected
were in dense gatherings with hundreds
of people
and it's spread like wildfire so it's
not just a dense city or a dense
community it's any person in a dense
environment you can be in a very rural
county you know people think New York oh
it's all New York City no no we have
counties that have more cows than people
by population you can be anywhere but if
you have a person who's infected in a
room of 200 people 300 people 400 people
now you have a problem this goes back to
the Spanish flu where some cities
canceled parades other cities didn't
cancel parades we went through these
numbers when when we had the decision on
the st. Patrick's Day parade which
Bernadette still enough forgive me for
but you can have a parade in a
relatively small city but you bring
people together and this virus has a
feeding frenzy where do we go from here
question of reopening which everyone
wants to do and everybody wants to do
yesterday I am and I am at the top of
that list we have to understand on the
reopening as much as we have this
emotion we want it to happen and we want
it to happen now and we can't take this
anymore
and everyone feels to say it is a
delicate balance remember what we have
to do on reopening and remember it has
never been done before
none of this has been done before so
anyone who says to you oh I know what we
should do I know yeah you don't know
because nobody knows and that's the one
thing that we have learned over and over
again and this place has never done this
before
also you look around the world you see
warning signs from countries who have
opened and my point is to our team I
want to learn from those other countries
frankly and I want to make sure we know
from our studying and assessment of
what's going on in other
countries that what worked what didn't
work and let's learn from those lessons
and you can now go back and look at
Wuhan province and look at Italy and
look at South Korea and see what they
did and see what worked and what didn't
work so let's learn so we'll listen to
the experts we'll follow the data but
remember this is a delicate balance what
are we doing on reopening we are easing
isolation we want to increase economic
activity that will happen essentially
through a recalibration of what our
essential workers remember we never
turned off the economy right the economy
is still functioning you can get in your
car you can you guess when you can go to
the grocery store you can shop you can
get on a bus the economy is functioning
we never turned it off we turned it way
way down and it's just the essential
services that have been operating but
the essential services have all been
operated when you will be doing in
essence on the reopening is
recalibrating what is essential right
you'll start to open that valve on the
economic activity and you'll turn that
valve
very slowly reopening the economy more
essential workers do it carefully do it
slowly and do it intelligently more
testing and more precautions at the same
time that you're opening that valve more
testing so you have more information
about who should be coming in etc more
precautions because you know that works
as you're calibrating and opening the
valve and while you're opening that
valve watch the meter
what's the meter the meter is the
infection rate the meter is those daily
hospitalization rates and there is a
cause and effect
you have density you have more people
infecting other people you will see it
within a matter of days in that
hospitalization rate so yes open the
valve slowly advised by experts keep
your eye on the meter the meter is the
infection rate and watch that infection
rate and if you see that infection rates
start ticking up which would be
undermining everything we have
accomplished thus far then you know
you've opened the valve too fast that is
the delicate balance that we have to
work through and that is what has never
been done before and nobody can tell you
today I know how to do that because it
just hasn't happened so what do we do
first we come up with a reopening plan
I'm not interested in political opinions
I'm interested in what the experts say
about this to the best they can tell you
but you have public health experts they
can study South Korea they can study
China they can study all the data that
we have you have economic experts that
can help you decide what is the next
notch of essential workers that can
actually start the economy back up and
have a consequential change but that is
a real plan and that has to be developed
and that has to be smart the wider the
geographic area for that plan the better
because this virus doesn't understand
governmental boundaries well i'm
westchester county
so you virus have to stop before
entering here and follow my rules no the
virus follows its own boundaries and its
own guidelines and it doesn't happen the
geographic area that is an economic area
a WorkFirst force area a transportation
area that's the relevant area that we
have to be looking at you have to
coordinate all these systems you can
start one system without starting the
other systems if you start the economic
system without starting the
transportation system and if you can't
run the transportation system then you
can't reopen the economy just doesn't
happen you have to coordinate the
schools with a transportation with the
economic system these systems work in
coordination the big gears and each gear
into meshes with the other gear and you
can't start one year with the other gear
stopped right that's the coordination
you're going to need federal support and
you're going to need smart legislation
passed by the federal government that
actually attends to the need as opposed
to normal political considerations
testing is going to be key and that's a
new frontier for us all so this state is
probably the most aggressive state in
the nation in actually getting the
testing up we test more than any other
state we test more than other countries
we test more than the other states
leading states combined and testing but
that's still not enough and we have to
do more and we know that the precautions
work the masks work the gloves work the
temperature taking works it's abnormal
it's different but it works and we have
to do it and while we're doing this we
have to remember to stay the course and
not jeopardize what we have achieved and
we have achieved much this afternoon
I'll be joined by other governors we've
been talking to other states Connecticut
New Jersey Pennsylvania Delaware Rhode
Island for the past couple of days about
coming up with how do we come up with a
reopening plan and can we work together
on a reopening plan and we'll be having
an announcement this afternoon with
other governors about just that the
reopening plan and as I said the optimum
is to have as coordinated a regional
and as you can I understand
intergovernmental coordination can be
somewhat of an oxymoron but to the
extent we can work with Connecticut and
New Jersey and Rhode Island and Delaware
and Pennsylvania I want to it is smarter
for everyone
for people of their state and for the
people of my state and this is a time
for smart competent effective government
nothing else matters I want to make sure
that we I can say to the people of this
state we did everything we could to the
best of our ability and the optimum is a
geographically coordinated plan I don't
believe we could ever get the total
coordination with the other states
because all those states have a little
different set of circumstances and facts
I don't even believe we should have a
uniform plan without recognizing the
state-by-state distinctions but to the
extent we can coordinate we should and
we will last point is the personal point
when is it over I have this conversation
a hundred times a day I had it last
night with my daughters when is it over
and it's it's a difficult conversation
because people want it to be over so
badly right I want the fear to stop I
want the anxiety to stop I don't want to
have to worry about my brother anymore I
don't want to have to worry about my
daughters I don't want to have to worry
about my mother I want it over I'm going
to get out of the house I want to get
back to normalcy I've been living on
this weird disorienting frightening
place I'm afraid to touch people this is
a violates the human behavior and needs
when is it over it's not going to be
over like that it's not going to be we
flick a switch and everybody comes out
of their house and gets in their car and
waves and hugs each other and the
economy
start something I would love to say
that's gonna happen it's not going to
happen that way it can't happen that way
can it happen in some communities across
the country where frankly they have very
low infection rates and they could come
up with a testing regimen where if they
find one or two cases they quickly jump
on those one or two and they isolate and
they track yes but is that going to
happen here no is that going to happen
in any community that has a significant
issue
no there is no going to be there is
going to be no epiphany there is going
to be no morning where the headline says
hallelujah it's over that's not going to
happen what will happen is there'll be
points of resolution over time what does
that mean there'll be points of
resolution
there'll be points where we can say
we've accomplished something we should
feel better we should feel more calm we
should feel more relaxed and it will be
incremental we're controlling the spread
we are controlling the spread you look
at those numbers you know what it says
we're controlling the spread I was
afraid that it was going to infect my
family no matter what I did
we're past that if you isolate if you
take the precautions your family won't
get infected we can control the spread
feel good about that because by the way
we could have gone to a point where we
said we can't control this damn thing we
can't control it it's in the air it gets
into your house it doesn't matter you
close the door it comes under the door
you could have gotten there we're not
there those numbers say we can control
the spread feel good about that
the worst is over yeah if we continue to
be smart going forward because remember
we have the hand on that valve you turn
that vow
too fast you'll see that number jump
right back but yes I think you could say
the worst is over because the worst here
are people dying
that's the worst the worst doesn't get
any bad than this worst and this worst
is people die
that's the worst and Winston Churchill I
mentioned the other day the end of the
beginning yes we can control the spread
and we can reduce the number of people
who die and our healthcare system can do
phenomenal work and rise to the occasion
and deal with this beast
it is not overwhelmed the health care
system we have controlled the spread and
there was there is confidence
to be taken in that and that's an
accomplishment and it was a heck of an
accomplishment those health care workers
for the rest of my life I will say
nothing but thank you to them and I was
not sure that we could keep the tide
from overwhelming our hospital capacity
and they did feel good about that and I
believe the worst is over if we continue
to be smart and I believe we can now
start on the path to normalcy and we can
have a plan where you start to see some
businesses reopening understand that
understanding the delicate balance I
think they'll become a point where
there's an announcement that we have a
medical treatment that you can get sick
but they found an antiviral medication
that can help you treat the disease so
take another deep breath when we get to
that point because okay you get infected
but there's a drug regimen that can help
you and then you'll get to a point where
they announced we have a proven vaccine
that's when it's over that's really when
it's over
they have a vaccine it's been tested
it's been proven they can produce it
you're going to get a vaccine this is a
thing of the past don't worry about it
close the chapter move on okay when do
we get there twelve months to 18 months
I can't believe you said 12 months to 18
months as Kara said to me it's 12 months
18 months when doctor found she says how
long it'll tell the vaccine
he says 12 months to 18 months when the
FDA is asked how long until you get a
vaccine they say 12 months to 18 months
that is the point when you can when you
ask me when can I do a deep breath for
the first time in five weeks when they
say we have a vaccine that's when it is
over but there will be points between
now and then we should feel more
confident and we should feel better well
I want it to be over tomorrow I get it I
want it to be over tomorrow I wanted to
be over tomorrow more than you want it
to be over tomorrow but that's not
reality
so let's calibrate our expectations and
in the meantime stay the course because
we have accomplished a lot through
heroic efforts of healthcare workers
police officers transportation workers
who showed up to drive those trains and
buses every day I mean people just doing
extraordinarily brave generous
courageous things every day literally
putting their lives at risk for the
public and we have flattened that curve
by people's actions which remember is
why those projection models were all
wrong the projection models were high
they weren't wrong it's a bad word what
they were saying is this is where the
infection will go if unabated what's the
question mark on whether or not you can
abate it can you put forth a government
policy but more will people listen to
the government policy you have 19
million people in New York
I could stand up here all day long and
say you must social distance you must
stay home if New Yorkers don't believe
it if Americans don't believe it
if they question their government if I
don't have credibility why do I stand
here and go through all the facts
I'm not asking any New Yorker to take my
word for anything
I'm not asking any American take my word
for it here are the facts I'll give you
the facts the good facts the bad facts
the ugly facts you get all the facts you
tell me what you decide they decided on
the facts that they would comply and
they've done things I would have never
dreamed that they would do and they've
actually made significant progress do
not reverse the progress that we have
made in our zeal to reopen and get back
to normal that's going to be the
challenge going forward but we'll do it
because we are New York tough and tough
is not just tough we know tough is but
tough is also smart and tough is also
United and smart as tough is also
disciplined and tough most importantly
is loving
well that sounds counterintuitive they
sound Republic no no no no toughest
people are strong enough to say love the
toughest people and that's New Yorkers
questions
we on a daily basis you're talking about
medical equipment for hospitals yeah
I'll ask the commissioner and you to
comment specifically but just so you
know how this works on a daily basis
every Hospital does an inventory that
they sent to us that says what they have
and what they need and any hospital that
is short in urgent need of anything we
provide them with that material on a
daily basis we do not have any hospital
that has said to us we have an urgent
need for X that we have not been able to
fulfill two caveats you can have
employees in a hospital who say I don't
like this protocol I don't like what the
hospital is telling me to do that's a
different set of issues second caveat
you can have a hospital say I only have
a three-day supply and that makes me
very nervous I normally have a two-month
supply yes I know that nobody has a
two-month supply of anything so
operating on that constrained timetable
that's where we are but Jim after we
received that question yesterday we
reached out to the hospitals in New York
City there was one the medicine network
that would like some new swabs we are
sending them 200 test kits today so
they'll have that but they're not out
they just wanted some in the future and
to the governor's point I was on the
phone with about a dozen of the hospital
systems today and just what he said
people get a little nervous about
running out of masks and things like
that but often they have like a 30-day
supply or 25 day supply and we monitor
that on a day-to-day basis with them so
as they need it we'll send it to them
[Music]
yes I mean and I think Melissa spoke to
that yesterday on the various protocols
and we're working very closely with the
hospitals as well as the frontline
workers to get them the needed supplies
but also specific to schools what would
have to happen first for schools to open
specifically in New York City in regards
to this planet if they have to work
together Bernadette I don't believe you
have you can't open one system it's the
gears which is in a non analogy in a
metaphor that doesn't work for anyone
except for me but that's okay cuz it
works for me
you have three big gears okay you have
transportation you have economic you
have schools so let's take just those
three you one start turning one gear
they all intermesh you have to turn the
other two gears you can't tell me to go
back to work
I live in Nassau County let's say I live
in Westchester County because I did you
can't tell me go back to work in New
York City if you don't have the transit
system operating I take the train from
Westchester to New York City I can't go
back to work until unless you're a
betrayer
unless you want everyone to drive which
will be pandemonium in four minutes you
want me to go back to work who's gonna
watch my children if the schools are
closed right for many working people in
New York the education system is who
watches their children during the day
that was one of the problems with
closing the schools in the first place
where people are very critical of very
clear everybody is a critic but people
didn't want to close the schools because
they said then the hospital workers
won't be able to show up because the
children will be at home and if hospital
workers don't show up then you have a
real problem because our major fear was
the collapse of the hospital system so
all of these things have to be
coordinated and they have to be
coordinated on a statewide basis
now look when I closed all the schools
in the downstate area there were many
school districts that disagreed we have
like 700 school districts in the state
right now all the school districts
basically make their own decisions
I know but in a situation like this you
can't allow 700 school districts to make
their own decisions you can consult you
can try to cooperate etc but we have to
have one plan at the end of the day
because then we have to take New York
and try to coordinate it with New Jersey
and Connecticut and Delaware and
Pennsylvania and Rhode Island to the
best we can and this virus doesn't
understand school district boundaries
and these systems we're talking about
don't work on any of these boundaries
schools transportation jobs they don't
work on a County basis it doesn't work
that way Suffolk County that's a nice
delineation for a lot of issues but none
of the issues that we're talking about
so the entire downstate area is one area
metropolitan area then you have upstate
you could argue there should be a
differentiation based on numbers or
could be a differentiation and that's
going to be the conversation when we
bring Connecticut New Jersey
Pennsylvania as I said look we have
rural parts of the state which are one
situation we have metropolitan areas
that's all going to have to be talked
through and reconciled
yeah we are we're talking to a number of
states and again we want to coordinate
as much as possible but focusing
primarily on our tri-state area they
talked about a tri-state area the more
we can but you also have to balance the
complexity in the unwieldy Ness with
coming up with a plan relatively quickly
that we can agree on so that's what
we're going back and forth on we're
gonna try to work with everyone but
again you have different states in
different situations and you have to
prioritize where you really need
coordination we need coordination with
New Jersey and Connecticut first and
foremost because that's where our work
force comes from you have a total
interconnection among those states
people who live in Connecticut they
drive to New York City they live in to
New York City they drive to New Jersey
there is a total internet
interconnection among them and that's
the primary place for coordination I'm
sorry if I tell you the announcement
today why would you come here at two
o'clock
except for my rapier wit humor well you
can have a hotspot depends how you don't
want it to find hot spot hot spot within
one mile hot spot within five miles hot
spot within ten miles
how about within a hundred mile
how big is a hot spot yeah but it
depends how you define hot spot you know
there's two blocks four blocks is it
people with 25 infection or 850
infection right you know we have I call
them clusters you have clusters that pop
up across the state as soon as you see
some smoke and you see a little fire run
there and tamp it out as fast as you can
and in Buffalo we have had clusters that
have popped up Nassau Suffolk
Westchester Rockland right they've all
had clusters the worst is over
are you in effect encouraging the type
of behavior that you're trying to
prevent I mean this sort of optimism
that might bring people out of their
homes that's why I've said the exact
opposite 57 times stay the course stay
the course it's working stay the course
stay inside take precautions right
that's why I say that a hundred times to
an annoying repetitive level but facts
are facts and I'm not gonna lie to the
public facts are facts numbers are
numbers
I need the public to believe in the
credibility of what we're doing right
credibility comes from two elements in
my opinion are you giving me all of the
information or are you spinning me are
you deciding that you can't tell me
facts because I may become too
optimistic are you manipulating me with
giving me information which is what I
think you're suggesting no you get all
the facts I'm not worried that you can't
handle information you get all the facts
second what I am proposing we do is
drawn from those facts right here's all
the information I work for you I give
you all the information
no spin no gloss no sugar no glazing
here are the facts I'm not worried that
you can't handle the facts you're gonna
get depressed you're gonna get optimist
take your irrational hero the facts
second component here's what I propose
based on those facts and I think it's
the intelligent response to those facts
I hope you agree with me that it is the
intelligent response and you follow the
proposal because I need you to follow
the proposal because it's all about you
if you the public if the people don't
decide to do social distancing nothing
works if the people don't decide to stay
home nothing works
I could never mandate 19 million people
you must stay in your house and if they
say as New Yorkers can say I think
you're being overly dramatic or you're
too political or you don't know what
you're talking about what do I do with
19 million people defy the order go out
and arrest 19 million people they have
to believe it so they get all the facts
I'm not going to shape the information
they get here are all the numbers but
and here's my policy based on the
numbers and here's what I suggest and I
hope you think it is not only credible
but competent and smart and I hope you
accept it just the best I can do
I'm not confident that the worst is over
I said if you look at the numbers 18,000
18,000 18,000 18,000 18,000 the numbers
suggest a plateauing slight increase but
a plateauing
which is what the experts have talked
about that's what the numbers say I also
say whatever those numbers say is a
direct result of what we do I've said if
we do something stupid you will see
those numbers go right back up tomorrow
period the worst can be over and it is
over unless we do something reckless and
you can turn those numbers on two or
three days of reckless behavior it's
like being on a diet right you get on
the scale every morning I lost 4 pounds
I lost 5 pounds I've lost five pounds
oh you're declaring that you have lost
five pounds forever no I lose
self-discipline today and I go home and
I eat like a horse and I'll get on that
scale it's gonna give me a different
number tomorrow it is directly a result
of what you do today the numbers down
because we brought the number down God
did not do that they did not do that
destiny did not do that a lot of pain
and suffering did that and that's why we
lost five pounds because we went out
every day and we exercised and we burned
more calories than we ate that's how it
works
it's math and if you don't continue to
do that you're gonna see that number go
back up and that will be a tragedy if
that number goes back
John I don't know the details of the
healthcare privacy law but I know the
healthcare privacy law is very expansive
and health officials are always very
protective of patient health but I don't
know the law well enough to answer you
but I can get you an answer today I can
sir okay but just so we're clear
Commissioner Zucker is a doctor and I
respect doctors I love doctors my
sister's a doctor but he's not a lawyer
go ahead let me get your legal opinion
medical doctor what do you think do you
know well I think I understand the HIPAA
law I think the issue here as I
mentioned previously this this is their
home these nursing homes are their home
and and we want to make sure we protect
their privacy in that sense as well it's
not just the issue of sort of saying
that there's a HIPAA law it's that
there's no where they're gonna go and we
don't want to put information out about
that no John
no it's a law it's a law but we'll get
you the legal we'll get you the law on
the matter but the law is also tied to
the spirit of the law and ethics right
you don't want to invade people's
privacy we give you everything I have
that doesn't invade someone's personal
privacy otherwise you know there's no
secret to number of deaths in nursing
homes right if to the extent you can
release it without invading people's
privacy releasing we're going to talk to
the other states as I said whatever we
do we're going to do in combination to
some possible with the other states and
we'll talk about that Atul clock could I
see a distinction in places that have
different caseloads yes right you have
your hand on the valve you will you're
watching the meter you're turning the
value opening the valve a little little
bit and then you're watching the meter
the meters the infection rates will the
meter respond differently in a rural
County than it will in a dense urban
County yes how do you calibrate that
into a reopening plan that's what we
have to think through
the new platform is working much much
better amen the Department of Labor
website basically crashed when it was
overwhelmed by the number of callers for
unemployment
unbelievably we had 1,000 people working
on the website handling the calls 1,000
people could not handle the input which
is just phenomenal but we changed the
system we changed the website and
Melissa can speak to that the new
platform got up and running on Friday
we've gotten much we've gotten a lot of
positive feedback it's much more
streamlined I think it went from 150
questions down to 20 questions and as of
about an hour ago before he walked into
this briefing the latest numbers I got
from DOL was 200,000 calls were made
between Friday morning and last night
they're on the phones again this morning
I'm I can't give you an exact answer
when the checks go ahead I can get that
to you I think as soon as the
application process is done and you're
accepted they go but I want to give you
something more specific than that's we
can get back to you after this so
200,000 calls were made not everyone
answers the phone and by the way for the
public who's listening right now if a
call comes up and you're on that listen
it's private answer it please because
that is the Department of Labor calling
to finish your process so when I say
200,000 calls were made 200 attempts
were made and then there's obviously
it's a percentage of that where they've
actually connected the calls where
they've connected they do close out the
applications and from what I've heard
that's been very successful I can get
you the completed number after this is a
question Nick
oh I would be look I think dr. pouchy is
great I think Americans trust him he is
he's been very helpful to me as governor
I've called him numerous times he's very
good at getting back and again as you're
walking through these uncharted waters
and trying to feel your way and sense
what the bottom is like I think he's
been extraordinary and I think it would
be I can't imagine that that I just
can't even with as crazy as things get
in this world and in crazy Washington I
can't imagine that that would ever
happen
anyone did I say anything we need to
correct anything that I didn't say that
was right for Buffalo Nick we've been
following Buffalo very closely there are
200 Kate positive cases hospitalizations
right now in Buffalo that's up from 225
of them a couple of days ago so it's
pretty stable right now so we're
watching numbers locally hour to hour
almost so Buffalo is pretty stable right
now but if it pops we'll definitely have
more people on it
[Music]
Jesse I know you you won't be back if I
tell you I'll see you in two o'clock